schön dass sie da sind bild julian
reichelt ist auch wieder dabei vor
lamprecht ja man kann es nicht wegreden
kanzleramts chef helge braun hat gesagt
wenn alle ein im angebot haben dann
können die maßnahmen wegfallen alle
haben ein impf gebot warum fallen die
maßnahmen nicht weg also richtig ist
dass alle jetzt ein impfangebot bekommen
haben aber erst seit einigen wenigen
wochen und deswegen ist es so wichtig
dass wir die impfquote steigern also
auch die menschen die beispielsweise
jetzt noch im urlaub waren zurückkommen
an alle immer wieder dieser appell lasst
euch jetzt impfen ganz schnell um eben
auch andere zu schützen die sich gar
nicht impfen lassen können die vielen
kinder menschen mit vorerkrankungen
deswegen das ist das gebot der stunde
noch mehr müssen sich impfen das und
deswegen brauchen wir zum beispiel auch
viel mehr angebote die eben nicht
voraussetzen dass ich mich ihrem beau
anmelde dass ich mir frei nehmen um mich
impfen lassen zu können sondern wir
müssen noch mehr da läuft ja schon sehr
sehr viel aber dann sagte er zu den
leuten und damit die dieses angebot ab
weil er soll jetzt sind wir die ganze
zeit auf sicht gefahren und das hört
sich jetzt auch so ein bisschen so an
das was sie sagen warum können wir nicht
so wie die briten ist beispielsweise
auch gemacht haben einen klaren termin
in julian hat beispielsweise den dritten
oktober neben deutschen nationalfeiertag
genannt um es dort zu
verkünden ab da sind die maßnahmen weg
also weise wie es eben geht ich erleben
dieser pandemie das sehr viel an
entwicklung auch immer zu verzeichnen
ist und vor ein paar wochen muss ich
ehrlich sagen habe ich mir eine vierte
welle dieses ansteigender infekts der
infektionszahlen noch nicht so
vorstellen können da geht es vielen
wissenschaftlern für ihn virologen genau
so und deswegen müssen wir immer sehr
maßvoll unverhältnismäßig vor allen
dingen mit all dem umgehen was wir auf
der einen seite an einschränkungen haben
und was wir an lockerungen eben auch
haben die menschen müssen sich auch
sicher sein die sich nicht impfen lassen
können dass sie geschützt werden und da
das entsprechende maß zu finden das ist
unsere aufgabe und ich finde da sind da
auf einem guten weg lasst euch impfen
damit diejenigen die es nicht können
geschützt wird von einem recht armin
laschet war gestern bei uns vielleicht
haben sie auch geschaut und er hat diese
interessante aussage getätigt gestern
hier es wird keinen weiteren lockerung
geben und wir noch mal ganz kurz rein
wir versuchen die menschen wollen dass
sie uns in freedom day schenken heller
es gibt aber auch menschen die wollen
dass wir weiter vorsichtig bleiben es
gibt auch menschen die weiterhin sorge
haben es gibt auch menschen die noch
immer in den krankenhäusern auf
intensivstationen liegen
und insofern
setze ich darauf dass wir beim impfen
weitere fortschritte machen dass wir für
die die geimpft sind keine
beschränkungen mehr haben und dass wir
vor allem keinen lockdown nach warum es
das ist eine klare aussage das
versprechen sie nie wieder lockt auch
als kanzler verspreche ich
lockdown ist das versprechen von armin
laschet sollte er kanzler werden sie
werden sich vermutlich gerade über den
gleichstand freunde in den umfragen
deswegen ist das ja noch nicht
ausgemachte sache dass armin laschet
kanzler wird sie haben eben ganz
interessant erzählt von der vierten
welle die sich nicht hätten vorstellen
können ist der begriff vierte welle
überhaupt noch ehrlich müssten sich erst
eigentlich sagen die erste welle nach
der impfung des hunde vollkommen andere
welle erst haben sie gesagt das
impfangebot jetzt sagen sie die es kommt
ein bisschen auf die impfquote an und
jetzt kommen sie dann noch mit der
vierten welle das klingt für mich alles
ein bisschen so als würden wir diesen
herbst und diesen winter weiter mit
corona maßnahmen verbringen und nur
unter gewissen
vorgaben irgendwohin dürfen
fußballstadien werden vermutlich weiter
nicht voll sein wir blicken nach england
75.000 menschen dort gestand warum
kriegen wir das nicht hin also wir
nehmen wahr dass einfach die
infektionszahlen steigen aber tun sie
über seine mitleser aber andere länder
die auf einem sehr ähnlichen im level
sind wie wir gehen dabei ganz anders vor
wir haben aber auch die erfahrung und
das in anderen ländern dann teilweise
sehr harte einschränkungen aber da
passen wir wollen einen weg gehen dass
wir die sache falsch regelmäßig ruft es
nicht das stimmt dann muss ich ihn
einfach einmal widersprechen wenn wir
jetzt nach england gucken keine arten
ein trinken und den immer keine arten
einschränkungen österreich kein alter
sie sprechen von australien das war ja
auch ein bisschen das gewünschte
regierung -szenario dieser
bundesregierung unter der berater nur
wird da ist inzwischen das militär auf
der straße und jagt einzelne infizierte
das was sie sagen auf einmal kommen die
harten einschränkungen zurück existiert
nicht mehr es werden auch keine harten
einschränkungen zurückkommen ich weiß
gar nicht wie sie darauf kommen sie
hätten ein interview von mir ja schon
letzte woche lesen können wo ich ganz
klar sagen dass auch aufgrund der
verhältnismäßigkeit in lockdown für mich
gar nicht mehr
vorstellen und von daher ist auch ganz
klar nicht erst seitdem das am sonntag
vom cdu-vorsitzenden erklärt wird
sondern wir können uns keinen lockdown
mehr frisch es wäre auch
unverhältnismäßig all diejenigen die
sich haben impfen lassen die vorher
maßnahmen entsprechende
sicherheitsmaßnahmen getroffen haben die
jetzt wieder einzuschränken deswegen
geht es darum dafür zu sorgen dass es
eben auch zu einer überbelastung beim
gesundheitswesen korbel ist und deswegen
müssen aber wissen deswegen sehen wir ja
auch so verantwortlich und deswegen sage
ich habe zum beispiel auch als
familienministerin es darf keine
schulschließungen geben es muss
präsenzunterricht geben damit die kinder
nicht wieder diesen bildungsauftrag
nicht dass dieser bildungsauftrag nicht
wahrgenommen werden und deswegen wir
reden nicht über einen lock down wir
reden darüber dass wir vernünftig und
maßvoll dafür sorgen wollen dass es zu
einer überlastung kommt ich will gar
nicht erst dass sie diese zahlen haben
dass die überlastung da ist aber müssen
doch stehen interesse daran haben daran
hat er alle das gleiche kessel nur alle
anderen länder um uns herum sagen
inzwischen es wird dazu nicht mehr
kommen deswegen dürfen jetzt menschen
wieder so leben wie sie entscheiden und
nicht wie die politik entscheidet wann
darf ich wieder so leben wie ich möchte
wann darf ein bundesliga verein wieder
so viele geimpfte ins stadion lassen wie
er möchte wann hören sie um es klar zu
fragen auf sich in unser leben
einzumischen also es ist unsere
verantwortung als staatlich einzumischen
da haben wir haben zu sorgen dass leben
und gesundheit der bürgerinnen und
bürger geschützt werden es ist eine
höchstrichterliche rechtsprechung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts gibt uns das
ganz ganz klar vor und daran ist unser
ganzes handeln ausgerichtet das geht
überhaupt nicht darum irgendjemandem
irgendetwas vorzuschreiben dass es war
weder mein ziel oder auch dann nehme ich
jetzt mal die gesamte regierung nach dem
bundestag aber das ist das was der
doktor derzeit immer noch geschieht und
das mit dafür müssen wir auch sorgen
dass es nicht dazu kommt dass es weitere
einschränkungen bedarf das ist unsere
aufgabe dass die menschen weiterhin ihre
ihre geschäfte offen halten können dass
ich einkaufen gehen kann dass ich
besuchen kann wenn ich will genau in
diesem stadium sind wir jetzt und das
müssen wir uns erhalten darum geht es es
geht nicht darum einschränkungen jetzt
vorzunehmen sondern diese freiheit die
wir uns alle gemeinsam zusammen
zurückgekämpft haben das ist dabei aber
noch einmal die frage ganz einfach warum
nicht so viel freiheit wie in england
wir haben so viel freiheit wie wir das
so viel freiheit wie in england warum
nicht wir halten es für sinnvoller dass
wir nicht ein ständiges rein und raus
aus einem block da und die wird es in
anderen stand haben aber wir haben es
erlebt den einmal schreiben die dann
ganz schnell wieder ganz harte maßnahmen
ergriffen haben und dazu wollen wir
nicht kommen wir wollen dass die
freiheit die wir haben auch bleibt aber
das steht ja dieser art maßnahmen
derzeit in all den staat dies anders
machen als wir überhaupt nicht zur
debatte die hospitalisierung niedrig
todesfälle quasi nicht vorhanden nochmal
ganz klar kein von jahr gehöre und auch
im sommer ganz schnell erlebt wie aus
wenig ins heim sehr schnell ist er schon
da war auch in anderen ländern ist ganz
schnell wieder explodiert ist und das
wollen wir aber in einer ausstellung
eine einschränkung aber noch einmal ganz
klar die frage warum nicht so viel
freiheit wie in england warum keine
vollen pubs wochen keine von stadion war
nicht wenn ich durch die straßen gehen
wenn ich unterwegs bin muss ich ehrlich
sagen erlebe ich genau dass ich erlebe
dass die menschen sie können ja kein
volles stadion erleben weil es in
deutschland kein voller liebevoller
restaurant aber warum kein volles
stadion ja ich glaube wenn das jetzt
wirklich das alleine ist was hätte ich
das alleinige aber nein hinter es
bürgerinnen und bürger zu schützen davor
dass dann wenn sie erkranken oder auch
diejenigen die sich gar nicht impfen
lassen können ich sage es nochmal kinder
unter zwölf können sich nicht impfen
lassen und da können wir doch nicht
zuschauen und sagen es uns egal wie es
mit denen eines auch übersetzt kinder
unter 12 wird es ja glücklicherweise
immer geben die werden wir also immer
schützen müssen das heißt diese art von
einschränkung wird
wir werden hoffentlich bald zu einer
noch deutlich höheren impfquote kommen
dass noch mehr menschen die
verantwortung auch für andere übernehmen
und dann werden an einer situation sein
wo wir zu entscheiden hat müssen wir
überhaupt noch irgendetwas ein stall so
das versprechen der bundesregierung
impfangebot dann fallen die maßnahme
gilt nicht mehr sondern es ist jetzt im
quote wie hoch muss die sein wir haben
jetzt seit einigen wenigen wochen
impfstoffe für alle wir haben jetzt
kreative möglichkeiten sich impfen zu
lassen die menschen kommen jetzt aus dem
urlaub zurück und deswegen muss jetzt
auch jeder diese verantwortung
übernehmen und dann können wir auch
entsprechend weitere lockerungen wie
hoch muss die quote seien damit
zum beispiel die fußballstadien ich weiß
die politik hat die bundesliga immer
gerne genutzt und sagen das kann er
jetzt wohl nicht alles sein wir stimmen
gegeben und ihr wollt die neuen fußball
gucken hier geht es zum beispiel darum
dass die schulen nicht wieder
geschlossen müssen da hat jeder so seine
prioritäten das ist auch wichtig dass
die schulen dann die kamera ist
anständig ist es anständig dass die
wirtschaft bundesliga gehört zur
wirtschaft und die schulen die sie
niemals hätten schliessen müssen wie
andere länder zeigen gegeneinander
auszuspielen das ist das was ich gerade
spiele überhaupt nichts außer denn ich
habe kinder im blick ich habe eine
gewisse verantwortung ich habe erlebt
wie sehr die gelitten haben in den
letzten monaten und wochen haben sie
dann die schulden wir wissen noch nicht
was das mit kindern auf dauer macht das
ist eine entwicklung gewesen darüber am
anfang auch gar nicht wissen was macht
denn mit kindern und deswegen das ist
für mich als familienministerin auch
einer der schwerpunkte zu sagen wir
müssen dafür sorgen dass die kinder in
die schule gehen können der
bildungsauftrag erfüllt wird und vor
allen dingen die eltern auch nicht
wieder an den rande des wahnsinns
getrieben werden wenn sie nicht wissen
schule auf schule zu das ist ein
hauptschwerpunkt den ich setze und ich
glaube wir sind da auf einem richtig
richtig guten weg aber der appell ist so
notwendig jeder der kann lasst euch
jetzt impfen damit wir diesen guten weg
weitergehen armin laschet gestern bei
uns gesagt weg mitte inzidenz 50 sehen
sie das genauso wir haben schon in der
letzten mpk uns darauf verständigt dass
nicht alleine die inzidenz ausschlag
geht da wie ein galaabend mit jens spahn
gesprächen sehen sie das genauso wir
brauchen diese inzidenz zahlen nicht
weil sie es auf in einer zeit entstanden
als wir noch ganz andere zahlen hatten
als wir noch nicht ausreichend impfstoff
hatten und deswegen brauchen wir diese
zahl nicht sondern wir brauchen eine
berücksichtigung dessen impfquote
gesundheitswesen und den anstieg der
infektionszahlen das muss und seiten und
das haben bei der letzten mpk schon
beschloss also kann man die 50 streiche
man kann sie streichen können wir 50
reichen herzlichen dank dass sie heute
bei uns fahren und damit zurück zu
[Musik]